I get so much restoration say something
I'm giving up on you.
I'll be the
one if you want me to.
Anywhere, I would follow
you.
Say something.
somebody
else to
start
you are
You saying good?
Something I'm Giving
Up
I'll be that one.
if you want me to
say
something
I'm giving up on you.
you
Okay.
Say Something I'm Giving Up
well
See some people are.
scheduling counseling appointments
I don't know. Maybe they're not. Maybe they're just finding water. I don't
know.
so I want you to
kind of take that song in you guys have
probably some of you probably heard that.
before
but I'm curious if you've ever felt that way.
You ever thought that way in your relationship?
I want you to take note.
Kind of if you were listening to it.
And kind of what was coming up what was happening for you
on the inside?
What feelings were there right just kind of
taking the experience it's because we're going to talk about that here in
a few minutes
It's a pretty powerful.
so as I said in our first session
we were designed to be intimately connected. That's the
way God has designed us.
And for most of us, you know in the beginning.
The beginning of our relationship that's pretty easy.
Right. We've we really don't have much to lose and I have
nothing to lose. We have everything to gain in our new relationships.
During that time.
It's typically easier to be a little more open with each other a
little more connected with each other, right? Y'all can remember
look back to your relationship. It was it was
much easier.
right we
connected with one another
we
look at each other's eyes.
right we
Answer each other's calls nowadays. It's texts emails
those kinds of things. We do all that.
We're attentive.
more responsive to one another
during those times and generally we
just like to be around each other.
right
But as time goes on
And life takes over.
Disconnecting from each other will happen
and can happen without us ever noticing
it.
Our level of attendant attentiveness and our level
of responsiveness just kind of drop off
slowly.
And over time the more challenging it becomes
to open up with each other.
I'm sad and I need comfort.
But I show her by withdrawing and being
quiet.
She sees this.
And she leaves me alone because she doesn't want to upset me.
or
she's worried about something. It doesn't matter what it is. She's worried
about something.
But she shows me anger.
So I avoid her.
So it's not to cause an argument.
These moments in our marriage are truly unavoidable.
And it's during these times when the arguments occur that the
enemy intensifies his attacks on us.
So in this last session tonight, I want us to
kind of answer the question what happened to us?
What happened to all of that what happened to the
connection that we once felt?
How did the security that we had in each other
just vanish?
Why does she no longer see me
as her hero?
Why does he no longer want to sit and talk with
me about his day?
Why cannot why can I not make her happy?
Why can I not make him love me?
These questions are really at the
heart of disconnection.
But ones that we cannot ask each other because it's
it doesn't feel safe to do
so anymore.
No longer feels safe to be that vulnerable with
you losing our connection with each
other sets off major alarm
Bells.
Think about the baby.
losing connection with Mom
all of a sudden alarm Bells go off. That's what happens
to us. Our sense of security is threatened.
Right? Relationally. It's threatened.
Sue Johnson I said talk about earlier she refers to
this as a primal panic.
And it occurs in our amygdala.
Too little Walnut shaped organs
in the middle of our brain. It's our fear Center.
Where all of our fears all these fears kind
of our noticed.
We sense danger of All Sorts, right? We have
a dog have ever seen the hair on the back of your dog's neck stand
up. Right? It's the amygdala and dog. It's
going up right here we get.
chills you have
A clown running at you with a hatchet and what happens right?
That that right there that's alarm Bells that's good. I was
designed we're supposed to we're not supposed to go. Hey, excuse me.
It looks like you're in a hurry. We're not supposed to do that. We're supposed
to either get ready to fight or
Run, that's what the alarm bells are. It's our
Panic system very natural.
So come along those lines I often use in my
office off and use the example of a snake or a stick.
Right if you ever walk along the path.
And you see something that even vaguely resembles a
snake.
The accuracy of your assessment in that moment.
Is not of importance, right? What's
important in that moment?
speed
right, whoa
It's got you got to get back. You got to
get back when we're in danger. We were not designed to
think we were designed to act.
Touch a hot stove, you know, this is kind of hot. I should
probably take my hand off or I'm gonna end up in the emergency room for a
little while.
We don't process like that. We feel it.
Oh and we pull away that fast
just like that, baby.
Just like that, baby.
So the fear doesn't only come from on the outside right?
It's not just you know, snake or whatever that kind
of thing or stick. It. It don't it doesn't always come from the outside. Sometimes
it comes from the inside.
So you've probably heard it said before that perception is
what's important not reality,
right? You probably all heard that.
When we're in need and nobody is there for
us we feel abandoned in that moment. We are
set up to enter.
A pain this is that anything that I was telling
you about at the end of the first session.
This anything is an attempt to
survive.
It's a protest over the emotional disconnection right
go back to the baby. It's what happened to
her.
She felt that disconnection curious. What's
happening. Try to get Mom's she's doing that.
All right.
Excuse me. So under all the distress.
It's it's this protest under all
the distress and the arguing in
the in the yelling. We simply want to
know.
You you simply want to know we all simply want
to know is your spouse there for you?
You want to know that she needs you?
You want to know that?
You can get to him.
You want to know that he'll show up for you?
in those moments when we
need each other we all have those moments.
So it's what we do next.
That's really important.
Can we ask to be cared for?
Can we ask for comfort?
Can we ask to be?
Held and soothed nurtured. Can
we ask for that?
Can I ask him if I'm important to him? Can I ask her
if I'm good enough for her?
if we can if you can
That's exactly where we're supposed to be.
We're reassured in that moment and on we go.
No trouble.
can't
This is where we're in trouble.
If we can't the alarm bell sound.
And they drive us to reach for safety. That's what that
video was.
that Say Something video say something
Right. I'm giving up on you trying to
reach for them.
for the other
We've reached for the safety of our spouse with the
hope that we're able to get to them.
That video it's exactly what was happening.
So what happens inside when we reach for each
other?
And they don't show up.
So I know some of you weren't in here and didn't get to get to see that.
So I think if it's okay.
Any opportunity any chance that
we could play that part of that again, maybe half of that?
Because I want I want everybody to kind of get the sense of it and I
think we started earlier so and I'll shut up earlier so we
can okay good. Perfect. Let's let's watch a couple minutes of that.
you
something I'm giving
up on you.
I'll be that one.
if you want me to
say
I'm giving up on you.
if
you
Okay, that way everybody can kind of get the experience of that. So
I as you were watching that.
You know you almost hear.
The ticking of the clock behind it right? Boom almost
like every second boom. It was just perfect.
So here's what I want you to do just turn each
other's a second little exercise. I
want you to do just kind of turn each other. I guess technically the third and
I want you just to share with each other. What was
it like watching that what comes up for you what thoughts what comments you
have about the video pay attention to maybe something it was
their emotionally. What do you see in that? What do you what do
you pick up from the the tone of the of
the song or the the words just
kind of share with each other for a minute? What what thought if
you go, well that was stupid or whatever. I don't know but just share
with each other kind of what thoughts maybe came up for you why
you were watching that? Okay, so take a couple minutes and do
that.
Okay, so
I'm curious if
any of you kind of hear the
longing
in that
kind of hear the longing and the desperation in
that in that song. You probably picked
up on some of those kinds of things right? I'm
not a music connoisseur. I don't know what to look for.
There's probably something very, you know important in all
of that.
Simply for me is I just hear say something to me.
Hear that in my office all the
time.
I'm just I just want him to hear me.
and
He doesn't.
And it's looked at negatively and it's like
this song comes to my mind all the time, which is
why I wanted you to see it because it's the longing that
we have there.
The baby if the baby could sing it
would be singing this song right say something say something
that kind of thing. I'm giving up on you right? I'm tensing
up. My body's telling me you're not there for me. I'm going into this
I'm panicking.
And I need you.
And when we don't when they don't show up.
Boy, that's really bad.
So since our
desire to connect is built in.
We naturally do what we can to connect.
to reach for the other
often, however
Our reaching is misunderstood.
We reach for the other seemingly innocently enough
we reach for each other. But yet it's misunderstood.
And he probably even had to say it sometimes before wait
a minute. That's not what I and that's not what I meant.
Almost every one of you in here is probably had to say
that one time in your life. If not, I've said it enough for you.
That's not what I meant.
That's not what I didn't mean for it to come out that way. That's not what
I meant.
So when it's misunderstood.
This is when now we kind of enter this.
This could turn into an argument.
Right we end up in this place in the beginning our office
our arguments kind of start off innocently enough.
But as time goes on
We find ourselves becoming more confused and
more frustrated.
By these arguments, but because they don't give
us the results that they want. Have you ever had an
argument? That didn't end up the way you wanted it
to?
most of them right most of
them
Well the confusion and right
and we end up confused and we end up frustrated.
The confusion comes from the fact that we see
ourselves we genuinely and honestly see ourselves
is trying to make the relationship better trying to
reach for the other and connect with them.
But it's not being understood that way. It's not being interpreted that way.
This is where we that's not what I meant. That's not what I that's not
how I said it. That's not what I said. We right we end
up in that place.
This is when we begin kind of showing the
other our frustration.
And if you don't have a good definition for frustration, this
is it I want to but I cannot.
I want to make our relationship better, but I
cannot make our relationship better. I want to reconnect with
you, but I cannot reconnect with you.
So I want to buy but I cannot this is how the argument
kind of.
Take over.
for us
the frustrations then
kind of turn into outright anger. We
just let it
let it happen.
Not being understood.
Not being there for you, right what the baby
was doing the baby didn't understand. Why can't I get you? I got
it. I'm pointing. I'm giggling. I'm cute. Why can't I
why can't you reach for why can't I get your
attention?
So now that's more panic and you could just see the
baby escalate, right? It goes from a look to a crying outright
crying escalated. That's what we do.
We escalate more alarm Bells go off if I
reach for you. You're not there for me more alarm Bells go off. This is
the protest the baby was protesting.
This is a this is what we do as adults.
After a period of time these arguments
develop a very clear and predictable pattern.
This is what Sue says. She's termed these demon
dialogues, which I think are very appropriate for
them because once they take over once
the enemy has a foothold in our
marriage right here it no longer feels emotionally safe
for us and we begin to slowly drift apart.
The distance that we feel right we
might be face to face but the
distance that we feel in this that we
kind of sense happening in the relationship drives our
attempts to reconnect because our
attachment need meaning our divinely
inspired internal design has kicked
into high gear.
It's in it's in these milliseconds of
time.
That our relationship.
Can take a turn for the worse.
And it's such a small window of time that nobody
sees it.
Nobody in my office is I'm talking to them has ever seen
this. They don't ever pay attention that they say I said, well, how does
that feel? Well, I do this. Well get it. Well, how does that feel? I well I
think this
because it's such a small window of time. They're
just reacting right because they're in a panic.
Nobody sees it happening to them on the inside where
it matters until it's too late.
So we panic.
And when we Panic we typically don't make
good decisions.
Right. Typically, we don't we therefore we escalate the
situation to kind of gain some control over it
because we don't want it to you know, kind of over what's happening because
we don't want it to escalate out of control.
But oddly enough it only makes it worse.
And around the cycle we go again.
Making it worse every time this is all an attempt to protect ourselves
and to save our relationship. It just doesn't look that way.
I wholeheartedly believe that at
the core of every couple argument.
is a relational threat
right
at the core of every one of our arguments is
a relational threat.
That is when we begin.
arguing
It's just a little tension we can feel it. We begin arguing because
God has designed us to be connected for
a lifetime. This is where our deepest fear of
disconnecting gets touched Pope way
down here way down here in our underbelly, right
hurts.
we panic
If I'm not good enough for you, you could find somebody who
is.
That's his deepest fear of disconnection.
Now in place of good enough you can insert whatever you want insert smart
enough.
pretty enough Rich enough
tender enough strong enough
Whatever you want it if I'm not enough.
for you you could find somebody who was
And I hear people all the time say well now that's not that's
what I know. He's not going anywhere. I know she's not going anywhere, you know that intellectually
but deep down there's something inside you
saying. Oh,
This could turn bad and I could be alone.
And so this drives us to fight quite literally for
the survival of our marriage.
but again
It doesn't look that way.
So remember what I said earlier about there being one
enemy in our lives. This cycle
is how he works.
This is exactly how he works over time and people
will live like this for decades without
any knowledge of what's happening
to them.
They read the books they go to conferences they go
and learn new skills. They'll do all kinds of
things and eventually they end up in this relational misery
go round. You want to call it that and slowly
Our Hope fades.
And that becomes a even scarier place for us.
all the couples in my office
That they're all they're all different. Of course, right? They're
all different different backgrounds different people all those kinds
of things but all of them have this one feature in
common. They're all trapped in this cycle.
So I want to show you visually.
How this works.
right what what I'm showing you in this 45 minutes
or whatever this turns into
it can take a while to figure out so I
want you to kind of see it visually, so
I want you to notice the queue in the middle.
Right. This is kind of this triggering event here.
This could literally be a million different scenario
even more than that. This could be so many scenarios. Imagine
every scenario in the universe. This is it's
like it could be this.
Driving cooking money sex in-laws
Hobbies family work
chores the like I said as many things as are
in the universalists that long that we can argue about those problems
though.
Are not the problem.
It's it's content. They're all content. And what
I want you to see in this is the process.
I want you to follow the lines the arrows
as we go around to see that process at
work.
Okay.
so
Justice Satan wanted Adam and
Eve to look at the fruit
the content
he wants us today to focus on that.
Because he knows that's not going to get us anywhere not on the outcome.
Right where we are in our marriages right
now today.
Especially if we're struggling.
Has been the result of or the outcome of or
i product of living this life
in this cycle without having any idea
living according to this that I'm going to show you the rest of
it living according to this without any knowledge that it's
there.
And you're gonna leave tonight knowing. Oh, okay. There's
something here. There's something here. What is this? And
it's I'm gonna try to go slow through it. Like I said because I want
you to see it.
And at least begin to pay attention to there's something else going
on here. That's kind of hard to.
believe really
Okay.
Okay, so when the Q occurs right start right
there and kind of Follow that line and it doesn't matter which which one
you are. You just can't happen to notice.
I'll talk a minute about in our an hour culture. Typically
women are the first ones to notice a
bit of emotional disconnecting.
They just typically that way not all of them. It's
not always that way but typically that way.
So we notice this queue immediately and then we get touched.
There's a core emotion here that gets
touched in you many times. It's just
simple curiosity. It's not a big deal, right? It's not
something it's nothing major a little uncertainty. Maybe you're
glad about something. Like I
said, nothing major, but it's there. There are some other kind of
core emotion that's present. But at
other times depending on your life experiences
or attachment wounds
the core emotion may be
any one of these that I've listed at the bottom that you
can see on your
On the handout there can be any one of those.
And just as a point to say something
about attachment wounds.
It comes up in in every one
of my sessions it came up today with a
client of mine and and a struggle
with his adult daughter and just
a big scenario there where she's not
taking responsibility and taking ownership for some
things that she's doing in her life.
And that really touches him one of those was not caring
for a child and one of her children was
abused.
And he's processing through this because
it comes up between him and his daughter comes up
between him and his wife and what happens is he is
processing through this today and he's talking about this attachment
wound for him.
His mother was a drug user and was not
present for him and had man after man after
man coming through and would leave her with babysitters to
go out and party. Whatever. Well one of the babysitter sexually abused
him.
So he's living the life that his grandson is
living now.
And hit so you can see when I say attachment wound
what this client needed in his life
was somebody to show up for him and to protect him. His
dad was in another.
State he was here and his mom wasn't there and he
was a kid and he needed to be protected and
he wasn't.
See how when I say attachment wound. You understand what
I'm saying? He needed that and he didn't get that as a
kid.
Well that stays in grained.
That stays ingrained.
right, and so when it happens with his daughter
And her not taking responsibility and his mom never
took responsibility.
For it never owned it that that's what that she
wasn't there for him never apologize. So he's left
with this wound and his mom died a couple
weeks ago.
So it's really coming up for him and now he can
never process and be healed from that with her. Right?
So it's very powerful when he's trying to shove
this responsibility taking ownership down his daughter's throat
because this is deep for him, right he trips
over this with her and he doesn't see it.
He didn't see it when we're talking about it today and he tripped over it right
our daughter Miranda.
Our daughter Miranda. We have we have these three
kit three of the four we have are adopted the last
one. Is she we sell guardianship, but Miranda what
you don't know about Miranda. That's a beautiful picture. She's bright and
smiley. She's a great kid, but on the inside, this
girl is terrified.
And she doesn't remember it cognitively. She doesn't remember
what happened to her. But if you knew Miranda back to her
head flat as a board.
And if anybody knows what that means, I mean,
she laid there and cried and cried and cried and
nobody came to get her.
She doesn't remember that up here.
her body does
Right, her body's going to remember. These are attachment wounds.
And Miranda man, she's
if there's two adults talking. Oh, she's gonna be right there. What
are you guys talking about?
She's wanting to know.
You're talking about me. Do I need to know that or if you're upset with
her boy she panics if you think
if she thinks you're upset with her.
she panics
because this wound for her is so deep. She
doesn't know it. She doesn't remember why she didn't remember that to happen
to her when she was.
days and weeks old
She doesn't remember that but her body will never forget it.
It'll always be there. So when I talk about attachments when you hear about attachments, it's
those kinds of things what we needed as a kid that we
didn't get.
And when it happens in in adult relationships you think
this is going to show up in her marriage later on
100% It's going to
show up.
It's gonna show up.
So
depending on life experiences and depending on attachment wounds
these core emotions here that show
up may be any one of these that's listed now
the instant
One of these is touched.
Right like for Miranda, it would be abandonment rejection. Right?
It would be loneliness not being
wanted. It's going to be any one of these right?
Maybe all of them maybe one of them specifically, but it's
going to be there.
When these are touched people immediately get into
their heads and the thoughts begin to race, especially as we're as we get
older, right? We have that cognitive ability get in their heads. What's happening?
What have I done? What's wrong? How can I fix this? Right?
So now we start up to scale here. What's happening right here?
There's so many thoughts and questions running through our heads and it's all inside.
It's all inside under the surface and your spouse
can't see it.
Because it's all up in here.
It's all working. So fast up in here can't see
it. They can't hear it.
The emotions that we're feeling then dictate the course of our thoughts.
It's going to dictate the course of our thoughts then immediately what we
show our spouse and when I say show our spout what
I mean is do or say
right what we do.
Or what we say how we say it what we say, whatever that's what
I'm talking about.
We'll talk about anger.
To some degree right instead of a sharing to
hurt or fear. We'll talk about this reason say the surface emotion here
irritation frustration anger aggravation agitation.
Fear all those kinds of things surface emotion. I'll put in quotes and
I'll tell you why here in a minute.
They kind of dictate the course. We'll talk about those to some degree, but we
won't share the hurt the fear of the pain.
I won't share that what we're feeling.
now I'm going to tell you something that
I'm not sure many people if any will agree and that's okay.
I don't mind I'll be different.
I don't believe anger is an emotion.
Just let that sink in for a minute. I don't believe anger is an emotion.
I know it's been traditionally considered one. I've always
assumed it had just been labeled correctly as an
emotion.
How I understand emotions right that just something
that we feel in those moments.
always believe that
but the longer I do this work the longer
I work with couples in these kinds
of things.
the more my belief that it's not
An emotion is confirmed now. I'll
say this because my wife's here God tell this.
I could be wrong.
Huh? I could be wrong. I may be wrong.
It's entirely possible.
but
if I'm wrong.
If it is an emotion.
It's the only one that needs a management program.
Right, listen drugs alcohol
overeating gambling. You
name it?
all of those means of coping with
these
deep core emotions
All of them are destructive.
And just like anger they all need a management
or a treatment program of some sort.
right
It's very intellectual.
Very powerful like rape think of road rage.
We don't call it rage road fear.
Right, we don't run up and say tap on the window because excuse me, sir. You just
pull down me that's terrifying my family.
Right. We don't say that.
But if I come up if I come up, do you
and I this is gonna be brutal. I would
never do this. Just so you'll know my friend who's a trooper.
I'm just telling me he would know I'm not gonna go
up and break your window with a butt of my pistol and stick
it in your temple go listen.
But that kind of road right? That'll get your attention.
Anger is designed to get our attention.
to get their spouses attention
that's reason. I think it's a means of coping promise. Just
not a good means of coping.
Okay.
So we only share these surface emotions.
Irritation frustration and anger. We only
share those and we only share those when we
share those.
And allow them to cover up what's really happening for
us underneath.
The words are the actions that come out are going
to do damage.
They're going to do damage right we're going to say things we're going
to do things.
We're going to become violent. We're going to go file for
divorce. We're gonna do lots of things that are damaging.
Out of our anger we can be critical or aggressive.
But all that does is push our spouse away, thereby exacerbating
their hurt or their fear that they're feeling down there
deep.
And we're going to make the situation worse.
so
just to be clear.
We don't always show those surface emotions. Those
aren't the ones that all right. Those aren't the
ones that always get touched.
sometimes our fear our fear
response is not to fight right we
have
Fight or flight, right? You've all heard that Firefly response.
Sometimes it's a or a flea fight or
Fleet. Right? You've heard that sometimes it's a flea response
or in avoidance response. There's another version It's a
freeze response. And then one of fighting is a fawning
response, it's ways of fighting
or fleeing. It's they're just different.
when one of these shows up
Right when we are afraid and like our flea response shows up
or whatever. Are we avoid something or we even become
more logical?
Right guys, we like to pride ourselves on. Oh, I'm The Logical one.
She's the emotional one. I got news for you. That logical
one is simply I'm covering up what's happening for me
because I can't let you in on that.
We're more logical in order to remain calm, right? That's what
they teach good skill to learn not not in it.
But because we don't want to make the situation worse we
use it. The problem is I can just make us appear
cold and uncaring I hear that all the time. He's logical
I can't get through him. He's like Mr. Spock. I can't get to him right
robot.
And so
That pushes me away keeps me shut out now how this
works. Is this here's the next slide.
When we hide these core emotions with these behaviors right
to criticism harshness contemptuous
talk distance logic
reason, all of those kinds of when we hide
these core emotions with these behaviors it
immediately has an impact on our spouse and it
hits them right here.
And I point to here we know it's here, but you know.
It hits us right here.
criticism
makes us feel inadequate. You've probably been criticized before.
Right. It says you're not good enough.
So it makes us feel inadequate aggressive aggressive behavior is
frightening.
logic and reason makes us feel unimportant and uncared
for
silence makes us feel alone distance makes
us feel abandoned.
It's all that makes sense kind of get
that.
That's important. It's important to understand that these behaviors
are not intended to do that.
But that's the outcome.
And because this is more like more than
likely not the first time this has happened.
You're not going to feel safe enough to share what's happening for you here on the
inside down here on the bottom. So you end up repeating the
same process meaning.
You feel something you feel some emotion the
thoughts run through your head and then you go
up in you know in your mind then you say or do something
to your spouse?
That touches them.
And around we go
again and it's miserable.
The more I protect myself because if you look at this cycle,
right the more I protect myself the more
you have to protect yourself.
It's a modern-day fig leaf.
What Adam did and what he did to protect themselves created distance
between themselves what I do to protect myself
makes put you in a position to protect yourself and
what you do to protect yourself then makes
me do it and around we go again.
And we know where it stops. It doesn't.
We just stop talking about it and then we'll figure out again.
We'll try it again the next day or we'll argue about a different topic.
Hoping to get out of this. It just doesn't work. This is why people go file for divorce because
they don't want to they want to get out of this.
Try to do everything they can to get out of this.
So the more I protect myself more my
spouse has to protect herself. We just end up pushing each other
away.
Then we kind of retreat into the corner.
That's making it more difficult to express these basic attachment needs.
I need you.
And then we guarantee our inability.
To reach for the other safely.
You are her centrifugal force.
Right. I'm not going to ask you to spell it. I know it's challenging centrifugal force,
right? It's kind of it pushes us away. It's this here
in the middle as we go right centripetal is the opposite true pulls
us together. This works like centrifugal force. I
had one lady tell me she was seeing the the cross and she
goes. Oh, yeah, the X gets bigger that it does.
bigger
The further away we get and the further away we get.
we Panic think about
Anybody ever been caught in a rip current?
Out in the right in the ocean. You don't rip current is Right
pulls your way. And what are they tell you is swim
horizontal to the right or parallel
to the shore to get out of it because if not, you're gonna swim against it
and what's gonna happen. You're gonna be swept out to sea to die.
Right. And so the more you swim against it the
tired you get the further out you go. This is exactly what
happens to us. The more I try to get to you what I
do to try to get to you if I'm a caught in a rip current. I'm not
going to go. Excuse me.
Who can you put your sandwich down? I need some help.
We're not going to do that.
We don't do that with our spouses either. We cry just doesn't look like
a cry.
That makes sense what I want you to see in this.
Okay this destructive cycle.
It's what we all get trapped into some extent.
And we can live here for years.
without ever
Any hope of getting out of it?
The problem with the cycle being all about protection.
is that
a close emotional relationship
close emotional connection cannot survive.
two people always protecting themselves
They cannot.
imagine trying to hug your spouse
and both of you are wearing a suit of
armor.
It's going to be a little clunky little medley.
right
Maybe loud depending on what you're doing, but you know what I
mean.
It's not going to be warm and cozy we can't get to each other the way we
want to get to each other.
So like I said a minute ago in our culture women tend to be the ones who
are the most sensitive to the emotional disconnection and
the first ones to experience the cue to do
something about it.
Once they sense this distance.
They began pursuing.
But because men have been trained to kind of disregard emotions.
many of them
Have a clue. We don't have a clue how to respond. So
what do we typically do? You share some emotionally you're trying
to reach for me. You want to talk to me, right or you share something with me? What I
typically do what a man do what are we always called?
Fixers right we got to fix it.
So we start we start trying to fix something go. Mow
the lawn or go do the dishes or go?
Buy something or build something or whatever.
All in a all in an effort to show our wives that we love
them.
Now it's probably not a lady in the house. It's going to go and that
works perfectly.
Right. Nobody's gonna go. Yes, I love it when he tries
to fix my problem by going to do that. I remember years ago. I was telling Candice.
I was giving her three points in a sermon it was gonna be
good of how to take care of the she works in
a family business and I was trying to help her with a problem because she
clearly needed help this problem because she was telling
me about it, right? I'm gonna help her fix it and she
looked at me and this is the moment that I probably I
grew up but this is the moment. It was really good. She said,
Do you think I'm incompetent?
If I hit me in the head.
No. No, why are you trying to fix it?
Right. I just want you to hear me. Right? You've probably all seen all of it. I should have brought
the video. You've all seen that the nail in the head.
You'll see that everybody seen the nail in it. If not Google it
YouTube or whatever find the nail in it. It's hysterical, but that's
kind of right but there's that nail we could just put
that's what we do.
This is why I keep paper because I'll take a rabbit hole like crazy.
I'll do that. So we all do that.
Wives we know this doesn't work.
Our Panic increases you're not there for me. You don't understand what's happening for
Me and You Begin seeking a comforting response?
But you do so in a way that ensures that
that need is not going to be met.
This is where
you're always at work.
You're never home. You never want to spend time with me. You're always on your
phone. Right? We've all said those.
To each other that's where those things come out come into play.
Why do you think we take that very well?
I think we like that hearing that. Oh, you're you're always
at work. You're never at home. You're always out playing
golf. You're always.
Mowing the lawn you're always fixing stuff. You're whatever no.
No, we don't like that.
because
we take that as a sign that we're failing.
And really for guys and I think you'll all agree.
That's the that's the big F word for us.
failing we hate
failing
so
because our culture teaches us our culture teaches
man. We learn it in man school. I don't know if you know about that. We learn it
in man School growing up that if you're not providing and you're
not protecting you have no value.
right, and so if we fail
We have no value.
So we feel inadequate.
And you feel alone and we're stuck we're
trapped in this again.
That sounds miserable. That sounds awful.
That's where people get and listen if you're there
and I'm sorry that you're there. It is an outcome of
what's been happening. It's an outcome of this if you're not there if
you're getting married or you're gonna get married whatever then pay attention
to this because this will happen so fast Adam and
Eve it happened then right.
Now get I get listen. This is a lot to take in
almost one to say something about like hey open up because here's you
a big old fire hose. I'm gonna pour this on to you. This is
challenging this can take months for people
to get
Right. I tell people that a large majority of
the work I do with them is helping them understand this. It's
like 75% of the work that we do
with couples that I do with couples is helping them get this
because it's like wait a minute. I've been living this way and you're
telling me that he's been crying for me all these times that he's
not there for me. Yeah. That's why it's happening.
And now he's just Frozen. He's like, oh I can't I
can't tell her that.
Can't this is what happens?
So here's what I want you to do. This is
a lot to take in. I just want to take you a couple minutes.
Here to talk about this with each
other kind of what comes up for you with this cycle.
Right? I think we put that that'll be up on the screen.
But before that I do want to remind you.
It's not always just women who notice the emotional disconnection. I
notice it.
I noticed that men do as well. We'll just we're worried.
We're worried. You're going to see us as weak.
If we ask to be comforted.
We're told we're good enough.
So we just don't bring it up. We just kind of suffer in
silence.
And be quiet.
So please don't hear me kind of perpetuating this The
Stereotype of the emotional woman not we're
all emotional.
God is emotional. We're all emotional. It's just
we adapt to it differently culturally. We
have these adaptations that we're taught. We're all
emotional we all feel
And so guys will feel this too. It's not just it's not
just the ladies.
Because we're both designed the same
way. All right, so just was very wrap up and give you a couple minutes. I
just want to you talk to each other.
What comes up as you think about this?
What thoughts come up for you? I hear about this cycle.
Maybe talk about do you see this happening?
in your relationship
It's going to be it's a little tough, but just kind of talk to each other
for a couple minutes and see what you come up with. Okay?
Okay.
Maybe you'll continue that conversation.
Later at home. I hope
and I'm sure.
Some of you have already kind of been thinking about how this
sounds very familiar.
Kind of in your own marriage and you're and you're wondering how to stop
it.
That's a big question. Right? How do we how do
we get out of this? And I don't want you to think
of it as a
Oh, well, we may start fighting we get in the cycle.
No, that's when it kind of just escalates. We
live in it. The enemy is right. It's why
it's predictable. It's why it's like if you're gonna say,
oh, I don't know. I'm not sure. I want to talk this about talk to
you about this. Like if I come home, I'm having a bad day.
I got to figure out how to put on a good face because I don't want to it's you're
not saying anything to or you're in your own head the Cycles already
at work with you.
Right because it's the outcome it makes itself necessary.
in your life
So you're probably already seeing it. So I don't want you to get the idea that
it's just something that we get into and then get out of no, we
always live in it until we're able to step outside of
it.
And that's why it's crucial to understand it and
recognize it. It's this force that says
don't don't be vulnerable. Don't let the other end. Don't
do that. That's the enemy.
That's the enemy right there.
So, how do we get out of it? How do we get to a place where we can both feel vulnerable
and both feel safe enough
with each other?
Safe enough with our spouses to
kind of share these core emotions rather
than being forced to cover them up or hide
them.
That's going to be that's my goal for tomorrow morning. That's
what we're going to talk about tomorrow.
The good news is you can get out of it.
The bad news is it's tough because the enemy doesn't
want you to.
right
his
his number one purpose
kill steal and destroy
It just soon you be dead. Really. I mean frankly it just seen you be dead.
He wants to destroy the happiness in your marriage. He
wants to destroy your family.
This is what he wants.
And and I I never think you know, sometimes I have
thought before is like wow, that's enough as you think Satan has ever
thought. Oh boy that I really went too far on that
one.
No.
He wants nothing left. Nothing less
at all than you. I wonder you be dead
because you can't share the gospel with anybody. That's the
first reason but he doesn't want your marriage to be
a witness to anybody. You destroy them marriage you
destroy the foundation of society.
Look at where we've been the last 60 years 70 years.
right
So he doesn't want you to get out of it I do.
I don't know you but what I will tell you is I love
you and I don't want you trapped in this thing because
it makes you miserable.
I want you to have the kind of marriage that God designed for
us to have it's open and honest remember they
were naked and unashamed.
That's where I want you that's my goal. You ask me. What's your goal
with couples Genesis 2:28, and they were naked and
unashamed.
Just like that. So my prayer.
My prayer is for all of you to come to
understand when this thing happens.
When it comes up in your marriage and be able to step outside of
it into something else.
Into that kind of relationship that you've always desired.
So I look forward to tomorrow morning.
To kind of talking about this and trying to help you focus on
seeing this a little more clearly stepping outside
of it.
and then into this new
relationship where you can reconnect in a
way that you
Never thought possible. Okay, you can recognize it
once you recognize it. That's great. But you
got to be able to do something else. It's the
something else. That's how do we reconnect? Okay. Hey, we saw
the cycle. We're in the cycle. I heard people all the time. So yeah, we talked about it.
This is that this is that thing that Larry's talking
about when we're there right the tornado They Call
It Whatever kinds of things that they want to kind of cyclone they call it all kinds of things the
enemy
They see it happening in their in their relationship and that's
what they say. There's happened, but we don't know what to do about it.
We don't know what to do about that's what I help them in sessions do but
in those moments of panic. Hey, this is it. What do we do now?
So tomorrow we're going to talk about what do we do now? How do we reconnect?
Okay, so
that's all I have for you, but I think they're gonna
They're gonna make you like do some exercise or something.
Yeah, get it up really and that was so good and you
want to take this in so we're what
we want to be able to do now and while Larry Larry's
gonna stay you gonna stay up there brother, so we're
sit down. I'll sit with you. Okay. Thank you.
So we wanted to make some time here to
reflect because we've got some time to do
it. You know, when we started talking about doing this conference. We
wanted it to be a really interactive experiential opportunity and
by saying that just now I probably freaked a million of you
out because remember people here I probably freaked a bunch of you out by saying that
but we just want to take a minute because we've got
Larry right here. We wanted to just get some honest response
out of some of you guys or if you had any question right
away, we've got some time to handle that
and or any reaction that you had
that was really special that you wanted to share and and I
don't mind setting the tone for this. I was sitting next to my wife and and
I got a really really lovely vulnerable response
out of her and she's so glad I'm sharing this about her right
now, but I gotta really lovely revulnerable France out of
her and it was really nice. So that was a cool exercise. So we
reacted really well to that. So anybody just put
your hand up and we're gonna travel whether you're over there over here
just put your hand up and if you've got a question or reaction that you
want to
Yeah.
extra fries
So if you got a question or a comment to
put your hand up, we'll come to you.
And if you don't we've got some in the bag we can use I forget
that I'm not I'm not asking any questions forget that.
Yeah.
So you were kind of talking about attachment style and
how that's formed as a child. Correct? Yes. So is
that able is that something that you can change your attachment
Style?
um, you know, I think
First and foremost. Yes. I'm going to say yes because
Like this client that I was talking about this morning or even even my
my daughter.
She recognized she doesn't recognize it yet, you know.
Oh you do?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Listen God is our ultimate healer person foremost.
But our spouses are not on this planet just
to hang out with us.
They can be healers for us.
I know in my own life what I've experienced right the
trauma. I've experienced what I needed.
I get from her.
I get from her and that heals me when God shows
up for us that's healing for us.
Right when we show up for our spouses that's healing.
when it's not
scary
and so I think when we know that when we're able to rest in
that security of knowing
You know, if if you guys got up and walked out early on
then guess what I can go to Candice and
I can say I feel like such a failure.
Like this was hard. I haven't told her after the first session, you
know because this is not what I do. I'm like
This is scary touching that part of me. And so I'll know
she's there for me.
That I'm accepted by her when that's ingrained in
us not intellectually, but full body
experience.
Then yes, I think that changes us. Are we going
to maybe
Tend to react to that way a lot. Yes, but this is
what I tell people all the time too is like with anxiety because you
know anxiety is just so rampant.
is that
instead of
husband
or wife trying to heal the other or trying to trying to
help them cope with the other or whatever with the
anxiety. Can you just accept it? Can you just hold it and
just understand it. This is what I have.
Right this anxious avoidant attachment or whatever. Whatever that may be this.
I'm just feeling anxious that you're not gonna be there for
me and if I can come to you and say I'm kind of I'm kind
of worried about this.
This is scary for me.
Right. I've told her a couple times throughout this thing doing this.
This is scary for me to do it. She's like
I bet it is.
There's a lot of people gonna be there.
Right, and they can make fun of you.
And and she's not fixing it. She's not trying to say well you're this
and you're this and you're this and you're that she's you can fix it.
All you want the reality is that's gonna be up here. That's not
gonna touch me here.
But when you just show up for me there man, that's security
that's like I can take you on like
you're one man, like Gideon did right I
can go and tell because you're with
me.
She's with me. I think that is big healing.
So that's kind of the long version of that maybe.
I don't know exactly but that's the way it
feels to me is that we can heal each other.
Jimmy's coming for you.
Um kind of bouncing off of that.
I had a question. So a lot
of times I hear in different things, you know, this idea
like codependency and you know not being needy and
so
Can you kind of explain the balance there? Like how
does like does you or me when I think about like what you
just talked about about being able to lean in on your
spouse? I immediately I immediately
thinking well, how do I not come off
as being needy or codependent?
Yeah.
I abhor that word.
I pour the word narcissist as well.
You think about kind of a core feature of narcissism is?
Somebody who always thinks about themselves.
Well, you start asking a narcissist to tell them
about life experiences.
You're going to find out.
They had to take care of themselves. Nobody showed up for
them to take care of them. So it make doesn't that make sense that they have to take care
of themselves to the detriment of relationships. Yeah.
So the term codependency I think is kind of the same
way.
Is that it's something that is kind of been I don't
know maybe culturally constructed. Is that because
I mean if you think about it and I'll just stand up here if
you think about it. I mean our culture was found
on Independence, right? We celebrate that
day Independence.
And so we don't we think dependence is
a bad thing.
Now Candice is not my air and
my water and oxygen those guys.
She's not that for me. God supplies that
for me, but what I need from her.
He supplied.
me with her to need that so what I look at
it is like, you know, if you think about kind of the definite I think codependency one
is kind of
it's misrepresented. It's me being dependent on you being dependent on
me.
And the kind of need that that's kind of the traditional listen old
version of it. We it's just now codependency is just
I need you, okay?
You need me.
I need her.
Right, she needs me and we don't pathologize that.
I think our culture does as a way
of us being kind of big strong man and those I'm not a big strong man, right
but just as big strong man, and the reality is
all I do is think of the the main
person I think of in situations like that is Jesus.
On the cross he could have in an
instant.
Ended all of this, but he didn't he was vulnerable. He
made himself vulnerable. This is
the idea. I think from behind dependence is it it
makes us vulnerable. We're not supposed to be vulnerable. We're supposed
to protect ourselves. I don't know. I didn't have never read
that anywhere never really believed that
and so
I don't know if that answers your question or not. I just
I don't like the word. I don't I know
people use it and those kinds of things and it makes sense that people
use it through kind of their exploration and learning about life and
relationships and things like that. But for me,
I don't have any trouble telling people I need
her.
I need her. I don't have any trouble telling people I need Jesus.
I'm having trouble telling people. I need my wife.
She's important to me and I want her to know every day.
She's important to me.
So
That one right here.
So when you were talking about kind of the residual things
that happen as a kid that carry
on into our marriage.
do you think that we need to
Deal with it with the say parent to be
able to deal with it in the marriage.
Okay one help me understand.
More about that the attachments so the
issues with attachments.
So the negative attachments that we have
that have come from kind of
like you said that parent child relationship like the
wound. Yes the wound.
Would we need to deal with that?
before we could
positively deal with that in the marriage like it
is something that is like almost like a prerequisite.
Like dealing with like with that parent. Yes, certainly.
Though I think that's the best sometimes that's
not possible this client. His wife his mom died.
That's not possible.
I do think that can be healed in him by
his wife and it's what we talked about with him today his wife
showing up and understanding that's what he needed. He has to
verbalize that so
Is that the best yes the right there
and in a room to size undoubtedly there
have people there are people that have been sexually abused.
That is in my own life. That is people that
I know that tons of people that I work with and
Though I would say that's the ideal person.
That's not the safest. That's not
going to be a safe person to do that. That person may
be in prison. I don't know.
dead so I don't think it's a
prerequisite
Can it if it's safe, yes.
If like if it's a parent then something like that and you've
tried to address it that way. Yes, I think that's the best person but if
you go and they don't accept you or they more
damage than of course, that's another
wound. That's the hard part about being vulnerable. But then I
think that's when our that's when our
spouses come into play
so I hope that answer your question. I'm not really good at this but
answering the question guys. Okay, I think you're doing
Great. Oh.
okay, I had a question about
The the cycle that you were referencing here.
Yes, would you say that?
Getting out of the cycle means learning how
to communicate.
with those core emotions or
I don't know. I'm just kind of
trying to gather what you here. Go steal my thunder for tomorrow.
Oh, am I here you
are right you you're
exactly right if the question if I'm hearing you
correctly is how to get out of it understanding what's
happening for us at our core and being able
to communicate. Yes communicate that
if that's the question 100% Yes.
That's challenging.
and that's intellectually we
can understand that but then we have
to be able to
move toward them and
share it.
but
we don't know how sharing it.
Is going to impact him. I had a lady this morning. She was like I'm sharing
the feelings.
She's a therapist.
With her husband in my office and she's like I'm sharing
these feelings with him.
Which she thinks is a good thing and it
is right.
The problem is now that she's verbalized that it.
pokes him
And because he then right she says you're not there for
me and I need you. I feel lonely.
Wonderful. Yes, but him not showing
up for her to get it he can't because
he feels inadequate.
And so his wall goes up.
Freezes up and then for her it's like
you don't care now. It's aggravated or
exacerbated and now we're in the cycle. Does
that make sense?
So yes, that's a that's a great Point. That's exactly what we're
going to talk about tomorrow kind of walking you through.
how to get out of that how to this is important to recognize it
but then being able to step out of it is really really
important
We got one over here.
Okay. Okay, go ahead. Okay. So
my question is when you have friends or family members that
are also Believers and they're going through a really challenging time
in their marriage. What is your responsibility or
any advice on how to come alongside
them other than just obviously praying for them on
how to help them. Yes, I guess
the question for me would be
are you helping just one of them or both of them?
Both both. Okay. Well one never bash
the other
Right. Don't bash the other and for me
what I would say is.
And I'll talk about this tomorrow.
All Behavior makes sense in context.
And what we're getting from one, we don't get the context. We
have to look at the cycle for context what's happening context is
life experiences, right including
childhood experiences current experiences
with the marriage understanding. What
is the behavior in context and being able then
to understand what it's
like for him and her
What is it like three words? It'll save
your life. Help me understand.
Right. I love you as good.
But help me understand especially in this relationship and
for you to ask him. Hey, help me understand. What is what
it's like for you in this situation and be
able to validate that first and foremost. It's not yours to
fix just understand it be able to hold it and understand it.
And then being able to help her him. I'm
not sure which one you're working with. Whatever. Maybe it's a kind of a couple thing, which
is good being able to help them
kind of see this.
A little bit. Do you think he do
you think whatever his position maybe his anger his
withdrawing whatever do you think in his
anger that he is scared?
Helping her to see through it. I I do
like to say a lot of times is what I like to.
What I'm showing you one I'm trying to help you here and
see something that can't be heard and or or seen right
and and I'm trying to kind of give you superpowers trying
to give you some X-ray vision.
I want you to be able to see through what's happening.
Out here or shutting you
out to see what's really happening is I'm talking
this client this morning. I see when I ask him a question. Oh boy,
you can just see the it goes in
his face and he is behind a wall because he is terrified of
answering the question. So with this couple
Kind of working and you have to do it slowly because if you just go dump this
on I'm kind of like me dumping this on you. It's like no, that's not it.
He's just angry or she's just cold.
Whatever if we perpetuate that, we're not helping
them being able to give them kind of an alternate. What is he?
What if he's doing this? What if he's doing this what if she's reaching for
you and you don't see it that way what if whatever right
giving them some scenarios and kind of helping them?
Maybe that way a little bit.
That makes sense helpful.
Larry we got one more for you. Okay?
I'm just maybe really looking for a suggestion. So what if
you both see that your marriage needs work, right? Okay.
Okay. Well, let's say let me come down there because what
you probably don't know is I have tinnitus, you
know, everybody know what tenant it is. Right sounds like a train Screech
into halt my ears all the time. So I'm gonna come closer so I
can actually sorry here, you know your phone.
It's at eighties loud rock music. So you both
know your marriage needs work. Yes, right, but how
do you get one another to come alongside the
path together
And and it's not like well one is
up here and the other one's got a catch up. But so that you're
both in sync with what needs to be work worked
on and it's not. Well, they need to work on this first
and then I'll work on this and then I'll write it needs
to be together it does and that's the ideal spot
asking. So what I will say is if there's maybe some resistance.
That maybe some resistance to come along.
On both sides. Remember all Behavior makes sense
in context
that resistance first and foremost needs to
make sense.
What is it about doing this it kind of
makes sense that you're maybe kind of holding back.
Or that you're not wanting to come alongside or maybe not wanting to
work on this it has to make sense in some
way and and they do have to talk to you about it. They do
have for nothing you I don't know who you're talking about, but being able to talk
about it and and then for us
To be able to understand what is
it about that? I mean I have to do like
I'm not going to lie it therapy's hard for
guys.
Right. It's just which because we can't if we
are going to therapy most of the time it's because
we've done something wrong. We feel bad. We feel like a failure.
We've not done enough. We're inadequate and so I have to help guys
understand a lot of time. It makes sense that you wouldn't
want to come to therapy. It'd be the last thing I want to do. I did I
did one session of marital 30 way back when I hated it.
Right because I felt like a terrible failure and I knew what I was doing it
was wrong. I don't so.
When people kind of offer that resistance, the first thing that I
want to do with them is make sense of it and even tell them I get it that makes
sense to me. I totally understand not wanting to because
when we do that
when we hold that resistance for them, it makes
sense of that for them.
They can feel a little safer. It's a process where
where this couple or whatever you might be talking
about where they are in their marriage is an outcome
of this thing working for so long.
And so it's not going to be hot. It's not going to happen in
30 minutes or an hour, right? We're gonna have to understand it and then
understand it a little bit more understand it a
little bit more.
To kind of help them feel safer.
It just takes takes a little bit of time. So the resistance
just makes sense of it understand it because it's
it's really important because that'll create some safety.
Okay, okay.
Thanks, Larry. Thanks Larry. This has been great. This
has been a great first day and it's not over yet. You're
gonna want to come back tomorrow. Don't touch that Daddy that
question that is gonna get answered tomorrow.
Don't touch that dial.
Right, but down the remote and if they have more questions,
what can they do? Mason scan that QR code
or we've got our if that's
not working for you if you've got a flip phone.
You can you've got your yeah or
rotary friend. You can go grab some index
cards back there drop it in the metal basket at
the imoj table and we'll be
going through those.
also tomorrow
the best session is last. We also
know Saturday mornings. Generally a lot of people don't want to
come to so we're enticing you guys with
some giveaways. So if you want a giveaway
you come back tomorrow morning 9 o'clock. Not only
will we have giveaways, but we'll have some coffee and some
water.
Again, and some snacks and it'll be a good time.
Thank you guys for coming. We're excited to see in the morning.